.
♪
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US FOR THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM
ANGLE" FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
TUCKER CARLSON, OBLATE.
HE IS GOING TO BE HERE.
HE IS GOING TO REVEAL WHAT IS
THIS SIMPLE BIGGEST CHANGE AND
THE WAY AMERICANS MAY HAVE TO
START LIVING.
FIRST, FAKE VERSUS REAL, THAT I
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
I DECIDED ON FRIDAY NIGHT IT'S
TIME TO SIMPLIFY FOR EVERYBODY
OUT THERE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CATERING, YOU
BUT THEY WANT EVERYBODY TO
BELIEVE THE OPPOSITE IS TRUE AS
WE APPROACH THE MIDTERM STRAIGH
FOR THE PAST MONTH, ALL WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT IF JOE'S SUPPOSE IT
MIDTERM MOMENTUM, THAT HE'S
TURNED THE CORNER AFTER A ROCKY
SUMMER.
OF COURSE THE OPPOSITE IS
ACTUALLY TRUE.
REUTER SAYS BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING HAD A PATHETIC 39 PERCENT
.
EVEN SO THEY SPEND IT TO ATTACK
TRUMP SOMEHOW.
YOU SEE HOW IT WORKS, RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ZERO COMPLIMENTS
TO POINT TO END ALL THEY HAVE
ARE THESE LAME ATTEMPTS AT
MESSAGING THEIR FAILURES.
BY EVERY MEASURE, THINGS ARE
GETTING WORSE IN AMERICA.
BUT DO JOE'S GOONS, THAT JUST
MEANS THEY HAVE TO THROW MORE
DIRT INTO THE WIND HOPING YOU
WON'T SEE THROUGH THE HAZE.
THE ANGLE, DON'T WORRY IS HERE
TO HELP YOU DIFFERENTIATE THE
REAL ISSUES FACING AMERICA FROM
THE FAKE ONES THE LEFT IS
RAISING.
FIRST, REPUBLICANS ARE
ANTIDEMOCRACY.
>> THE NEW REPUBLICANS ARE.
THEY ARE EXTREME.
THAT DEMOCRACY IS REALLY ESTATE
SPIRIT.
>> IT'S INSURRECTION, THIS MOP
THAT CAME TO ATTACK OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THEY OVERHAULED THEIR VOTING
SYSTEM AFTER 2000.
THEY MAKE BIG CHANGES EVEN AFTE
2020.
THEY HAVE REASONS TO ACTUALLY
TRUST THE SYSTEM IN FLORIDA, AN
LAST TIME I CHECKED, THEY COUNT
THE VOTES ON ELECTION NIGHT
GREAT WHAT A NOVEL CONCEPT.
>> YOU CAN LOOK AT ANY NUMBER O
DIFFERENT METRICS FOR IT RIGHT
WING EXTREMISM IS ON THE RISE.
THERE IS NO QUESTION.
EXTREMISM IS ON THE RISE IN THI
COUNTRY.
IT IMPOSES A VERY REAL NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT.
>> THIS IS A CULTURAL
NATIONALISM.
IT IS RISING IN AMERICA.
>> FALSE, THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
PERSON AT THE WHITE HOUSE, AT
THE DNC, AND AT THE WASHINGTON
POST WHO ACTUALLY BELIEVES THAT
IF REPUBLICANS WIN IN 2020 TO
AND 2024, WE WILL NO LONGER HAV
ELECTIONS.
IT IS FASCISM TIME AND THE
UNITED STATES.
EXTREMISM RUNS AMOK FOR EIGHT I
YOU BELIEVE ANY OF THAT, YOU AR
JUST A SUCKER.
WHAT ABOUT THE NEXT FAKE.
THAT SOMEHOW CONSERVATIVE
POLICIES ARE ANTI- WOMEN.
>> REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN SO
SCARY IN WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT PREY TAKING AWAY WOMEN'S
RIGHTS TO VOTE AND WOMEN'S
RIGHTS TO CHOOSE PRICKING HEAT
WOMEN'S RIGHTS IN GENERAL ARE
UNDER ATTACK THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES.
>> ATTACKS ON WOMEN'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS FROM ELECTED
IN CONGRESS PRICKING A FALSE,
REALLY?
WOMEN ARE GOING TO BE LOCKED IN
THE KITCHEN WEARING APRONS.
DO YOU THINK I WOULD BE FOR THA
MOVEMENT?
I DON'T EVEN COOK WELL ENOUGH T
DO THAT.
DEMOCRAT STRONGHOLDS, WOMEN
CAN'T EVEN GO OUT JOGGING
WITHOUT WEARING ABOUT BEING
ASSAULTED.
HOW OUR STORY THAT THE DEMOCRAT
HAVE CAUSED GOOD FOR WOMEN?
SOME OF THAT IS GOOD FOR LIVING
ALONE.
>> THE FACT IS STRONG WOMEN ARE
ON THE RISE THROUGHOUT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY INCLUDING
MINORITY WOMEN.
THERE IS NEWLY ELECTED BY A
FLORIST, ALSO IN TEXAS THERE IS
MONICA de LA CRUZ, AND KATHY
GARCIA.
IN INDIANA, IS VYING FOR A HOUS
SEAT, A PHENOMENAL CANDIDATE
RUNNING TO UNSEAT SPREADSHEET I
DOWN JUST EIGHT POINTS FROM THE
LATEST AVERAGE, SHE SHOULD BE
THE NEXT GOVERNOR.
THE LEFT DOESN'T CONSIDER ANY O
THOSE WOMEN, CERTAINLY BELIEVE
IN POPULISM OR AMERICAN FIRST
POLICIES.
THERE IS THE ULTIMATE FATE.
THAT REPUBLICANS ARE RACIST AT
HEART.
>> ANOTHER VICIOUS SMEAR WITH
ZERO EVIDENCE.
IF THERE IS RACISM ON THE RISE
AND THE UNITED STATES, IT IS
FOUND IN LIBERAL POLICIES THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY HARM
MINORITIES.
A BANK OF AN ORG FOUND INFLATIO
SHOCK OF 2021 DISPROPORTIONATEL
AFFECTED AFRICAN-AMERICANS
AFRICAN-AMERICANS HISPANIC AND
LATINO COMMUNITY.
IT'S NOT JUST THE ECONOMY,
DEMOCRATS ARE IGNORING THE
NIGHTMARISH PROBLEMS FACING
AMERICANS WHICH OF COURSE THE
LEFT-WING POLICIES THEMSELVES
CREATED.
MIKE HOW GOVERNMENT RUN SCHOOLS
ARE FAILING OUR KIDS.
TILFORD LOCKDOWNS HAVE LED TO
PLUMMETING TEST SCORES.
OF WASHINGTON, D.C. COVID VAX
MANDATE IS GOING TO PREVENT
ABOUT 40 PERCENT OF BLACK
STUDENTS FROM EVEN ENTERING THE
CLASSROOM WHEN THEY START
ENFORCING THE MANDATE.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> YES I DO TO DRESS UP
SOMETIMES, BUT IT'S THAT
USERNAME WHERE THIS IS THE ONLY
ONE THAT ACTUALLY DOES MAKE
SENSE.
>> YOUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE IN
SHAMBLES.
THEY TREAT PARENTS IS THE
ENEMIES AND FAR LEFT ACTIVIST I
THE BRAVE HEROES TRYING TO
THWART THE PARENTS.
LET ME MAKE A PREDICTION, WITHI
THE DECADE, THERE WILL BE A HUG
EXODUS OF CHRISTIAN FAMILIES
FROM PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
IT'S JUST GOING TO HAPPEN.
ANOTHER REAL ISSUE VERSUS OTHER
FAKE SCUM OF THE YOUNG PIGS WHO
ARE NOW FEELING EMPOWERED BY
DEMOCRAT POLICIES TO GO ON
RACIST RAMPAGES AND KILLING
SPREES.
>> NO BACON, NO FAKING.
[BLEEP]
>> Laura: THEN WILL WERE TO
COPYCATS TO KILL A WHITE OLD
LADY WHILE GRANDKIDS ARE IN THE
CAR.
WITH THE MESSAGE OF, THE CRIME
AND DO NO TIME FOR IT IS IT ANY
SHOCK THAT CRIME IS OUT OF
CONTROL UNITED STATES?
A DANGEROUS SHORTAGE OF POLICE
OFFICERS ACROSS AMERICA, AND NO
OF COURSE, CRIME IS CREEPING
INTO THE SUBURBS.
ONE OF THE OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON
, DC.
WITNESSES SAY GUN AND HAMMER
WIELDING SUSPECTS WALTZED INTO
JEWELRY STORE, SMASHED GLASS
CASES AND RAN OUT OF JEWELRY.
THESE MATCH AND GRABS HAVE
BECOME AN EPIDEMIC ACROSS THE
NATION.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE ACTUALLY
MAKING EUPORA BY THE DAY.
SO IF YOUR WAGES ARE LOWER NOW
THAN THEY WERE A YEAR AGO,
BECAUSE OF THE COST OF LIVING
HAS GONE UPWARD YOU MAY BE
WORKING MORE THAN ONE JOB TO PA
THE BILLS AND INFLATION IS
EATING AWAY AT YOUR MONEY, AT
YOUR BOTTOM LINE.
JUST THIS WEEK A GALA PILL
REVEALED A MAJORITY OF AMERICAN
SAY INFLATION IS CAUSING THEM
PERSONAL HARDSHIP.
THE DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE.
OF COURSE THEY NEVER WANT YOU T
FOCUS ON THE ISSUE OF THE BIDEN
FOREIGN POLICY COLLAPSE.
WE ARE POURING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN THE UKRAINE.
DO I EVEN NEED TO REMIND YOU
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN
AFGHANISTAN?
OF COURSE NOT.
WE HAVE ZERO CHINA CHATTERJEE,
NOTHING I CAN SEE.
DEMOCRATS ARE PUTTING US ON PAS
HIS SUBSERVIENCE.
INSTEAD OF AS TAKING CHARGE, OR
BEGGING THEM TO TALK TO AS.
CAN KEEP MY IS THAT PRESIDENT X
WILL RECOGNIZE THE BENEFITS OF
GETTING BOTH OF US MOVING IN TH
SAME DIRECTION.
THERE IS NO BIGGER THREAT.
THEN THE CLIMATE CRISIS.
>> BEGGING PRESIDENT XI.
FOR CHOICE ISN'T ABOUT CHOOSING
OR ANTI- IN NOVEMBER, BUT IT'S
ABOUT TRUTH OR FICTION, REAL OR
FAKE.
COMMON SENSE, OR WOKE FANTASIES.
DEMOCRATS ARE GUILTY OF ALMOST
EVERY MALEVOLENT ACT THAT THEY
ATTRIBUTE TO SO EVERY TIME THE
LEFT TRIES TO TURN THEIR
CONVERSATION TO DRONING ON ABOU
AND SOME IN NEW JERSEY, MAYBE
THEY TRIED TO GET IT TO FOCUS O
SOMETHING CONTROVERSIAL, LINK
MASTERS AND ARIZONA POSTED YEAR
AGO.
JUST UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING.
>> DISTRACTION.
>> EITHER YOUR LIVES ARE GOING
TO GET BETTER BY ELECTING
REPUBLICANS, OR YOUR LIVES WILL
CONTINUE TO GET WORSE BY KEEPIN
DEMOCRATS IN CHARGE.
LOOK NO FURTHER INTO HOW
CALIFORNIA IS DOING.
THEY HAD A CHANCE TO RECALL
GAVIN NEWSOM THE GOVERNOR, BUT
THEY DIDN'T.
NOW, IT IS BLACKOUTS, CRIME, AN
MORE SANCTUARY POLICIES FOR
ILLEGALS.
AND DON'T FORGET, GETTING RID O
GAS POWERED CARS.
GOOD LUCK GETTING TO YOUR TWO
JOBS IN ELECTRIC CAR THAT YOU
CAN CHARGE BECAUSE OF ROLLING
BLACKOUTS.
THEY WENT FAIR DEBATE EVERY TIME
.
SO ALL OF THEIR LEFT WITH IS TH
POLITICS AND DEMONIZATION.
THEY LEAVE THEIR RIDGING TO
RELENTLESSLY ENFORCE THE
NARRATIVE OF THEIR CHOOSING.
WE, WE CAN APPEAL TO PEOPLE ON
THE RE